>> TUCKER: AMERICA OUGHT TO GIVE
AMNESTY TO ALL ILLEGAL ALIENS
WITHIN OUR BORDERS NO MATTER HOW
MANY THEY ARE.
THE LEADERSHIP OF BOTH PARTIES
BELIEVES THIS.
THE PROBLEM IS VOTERS DON'T
BELIEVE IT.
THEY STRONGLY DISAGREE AND HAVE
FOR DECADES.
THEY SAID SO IN POLLING
CONSISTENTLY BUT INSTEAD OF
PAYING ATTENTION TO WHAT THE
PUBLIC WANTS AS USUAL THE
PARTIES IGNORE IT AND INSTEAD
WORK TOGETHER TO DO WHAT THEY
WANT BY STEALTH.
THEIR LATEST GAMBIT IS CALLED HR
5038, A BILL CALLED THE FARM
WORK FORCE MODERNIZATION ACT OF
2019.
AS USUAL THE NAME IS ORWELLIAN.
THE BILL DOES NOT MODERNIZE
AMERICA'S WORK FORCE.
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
IT'S DESIGNED TO KEEP OUR
FARMING PRACTICES PRIMITIVE AND
DEPENDENT UPON LOW WAGE MANUAL
LABOR.
THE BILL WHICH REMARK BY HAS A
TOTAL OF 24 REPUBLICAN
CO-SPONSORS, WOULD GIVE AMNESTY
TO ILLEGAL GRINT FARM WORKERS IN
THE UNITED STATES, PRETTY MUCH
ALL OF THEM.
EVEN ILLEGAL ALIENS CONVICTED OF
CRIME WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
PERMANENT RESIDENCY AND
CITIZENSHIP.
BENEFICIARIES WOULD NOT HAVE TO
PAY ANY BACK TAXES.
THEY QUALIFY EVEN IF THEY
SKIPPED COURT HEARINGS OR SNUCK
BACK AFTER BEING DEPORTED.
DON'T YOU TRY SOMETHING LIKE
THAT AS A U.S. CITIZEN.
CONGRESS WILL HAVE NO MERCY BUT
FOR FOREIGN NATIONALS, NO
PROBLEM.
HOW MANY FOREIGN NATIONALS WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THIS ACT IF IT
BECAME LAW?
NO ONE KNOWS.
THE PRO-AM NECESSARITY GROUP
FARM WORKER JUSTICE ESTIMATES
THAT AT LEAST 1.2 MILLION LEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WOULD BE ELIGIBLE BUT
IF HISTORY IS ANY GUIDE AND IT
IS THE ACTUAL NUMBER WOULD BE
FAR, FAR HIGHER AND THAT'S
ASSUMING THE BILL WOULD RESTRICT
IT TO ACTUAL FARM WORKERS.
IT IMPOSES VERY LOW DOCUMENT
STANDARDS.
THOSE APPLYING FOR AMNESTY CAN
SUBMIT ALL KINDS OF DIFFERENT
DOCUMENTS.
THERE IS NO PENALTY FOR FRAUD.
IN OTHER WORDS, THERE WOULD BE
NO REASON NOT TO SUBMIT A BOGUS
APPLICATION.
NEEDLESS TO SAY MANY PEOPLE
WOULD.
JUST AS THEY DID 30 YEARS AGO
DURING THE RONALD REAGAN
AMNESTY.
THAT SUPPOSEDLY LIMITED FARM
WORKER AMNESTY DLUNS OF
THOUSANDS OF FRAUDULENT
APPLICATIONS.
HERE'S THE KEY.
MOST WERE APPROVED ANYWAY.
IN SOME CASES EVEN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WHO ARRIVED IN THIS
COUNTRY AFTER AMNESTY BECAME LAW
WERE ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM THE
AMNESTY.
THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A MINUTE.
IT WAS A JOKE.
NOW THEY WANT TO DO IT AGAIN BUT
ON A MUCH LARGER SCALE SO TO SUM
UP, THE FARM WORK FORCE
MODERNIZATION ACT OF 2019 WOULD
REWARD LAW BREAKING, EXACERBATE
THE BORDER CRISIS AND UNDERMINE
THE ALREADY STALLED WAGES OF
AMERICAN BLUE COLLAR WORKERS.
IT'S PRETTY MUCH THE MIRROR
IMAGE, THE EXACT OPPOSITE OF
WHAT DONALD TRUMP RAN ON JUST
THREE YEARS AGO AND YET MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS LIKE TOM COLE AND
MORE THAN 20 OTHER REPUBLICANS
ARE NOW FIGHTING TO MAKE IT LAW.
WHY IS THAT?
YOU'VE GOT TO WONDER.